you
have you ever heard someone say they're
blind as a bat
well that expression is a bit misguided
during the day some kinds of bats can
see almost as well as humans but when
the Sun Goes Down
nocturnal bats rely on their ears more
than their eyes to navigate this special
navigation process is called
echolocation in echolocation bats use a
combination of their voice ears and
echoes to create a perceptual map that
allows them to see in the dark you might
be wondering where an echo comes from an
echo is the reflection of sound reaching
a listener sound is a vibration that
ripples away from its source in waves
the rate at which this vibration occurs
is called its frequency sound waves at
high frequencies are high-pitched humans
can hear sounds at frequencies between
20 and 20,000 waves per second and don't
perceive pitches outside that range bats
on the other hand can hear and produce
sound at frequencies over 100,000 waves
per second way beyond the range of human
hearing here we've slowed down a bats
chirp so you can hear it this chirp is
the first step in the process of bat
echolocation the primary sound that the
bat will use to detect information about
its surroundings the bat listens as the
chirp leaves its body and bounces off
its surroundings when the sound returns
to the bat the cartilage of the outer
ear funnels the sound waves into the ear
canal the waves then reach the eardrum
which vibrates in response these
vibrations are transferred further into
the ear to the basilar membrane which
runs the length of the cochlea if you
uncoil the cochlea and the basilar
membrane they would look like this
each area of the membrane moves in
response to a particular frequency then
the cochlea converts these vibrations
into nerve impulses for the brain to
interpret the bat echolocate so fast
that it can track down a dinner of
insects moving around in complete
darkness special muscles in its throat
make it possible for the bat to chirp
160 to 190 times
second because it receives so much
information at once it has to
differentiate relevant information from
signal clutter to do this the bat emits
chirps of varying frequency patterns
each of which echoes off objects
differently depending on the objects
size shape and distance from the bat
then by analyzing resulting echo
intensities it creates a mental map of
its surrounding physical space when
looking for prey the bat first sends out
low-frequency chirps over a wide range
larger objects will reflect more intense
echoes but it's often the smaller
objects like insects that the bat is
targeting once a bat receives low
intensity echoes from small potential
prey it will remit a high frequency
chirp directed toward it when both high
and low frequency echoes return to the
bat it is able to ignore the now
irrelevant low-frequency waves that
reflect from the trees or rocks that
surround its meal to gauge how far away
a given object is the bat analyzes the
time delay between when it hears its
chirp and perceives the resulting echo
directional information comes from
comparing information the bat receives
in each year for example let's imagine
that a bats chirp echoes back from an
insect to this side of the bat
since this ear is closer to the insect
it will receive the sound before the
other ear by interpreting the difference
between when it receives the echo in
each year the bat can guide itself
towards the insect that's our only one
type of animal that uses echolocation
killer whales dolphins porpoises and
some birds echolocate as well scientists
who develop sonar and radar got their
ideas from the study of echolocation in
bats and whales the US Navy and other
research groups are especially
interested in echolocation because it
could lead to even more technology maybe
now you'll think twice the next time
someone says blind as a bat
you
you